يعود الصراع الى دير الزور بسوريا في ظل
مشهد سياسي وعسكري يتحول سريعا في انحاء
مختلفه من البلاد
هذه المره على صوره اشتباكات بينما تسمى
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ومجلس دير الزور
العسكري شراره المواجهه تعود لاعتقال قوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه رئيس مجلس دير الزور
العسكري احمد الخبيل واخرين وكانت قوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه قد اشرفت على تشكيل
مجلس دير الزور العسكري في نهايه العام
2016 بقياده احمد الخبير والخبيل ينحدر من
عشيره بكير التابعه لقبيله العقيدات احدى
اكبر المكونات القبليه في المنطقه لكن بعد
ذلك تفجرت الخلافات في اكثر من مره بينها
وبين قياده المجلس المكون من 4000 عنصر
فما يوصف بالاحتقان متجدد وليس الاول في
المنطقه
والاشتباكات تاخذ طابعا عشائريا ولا تهدا
مع كل خلاف وهو الخلاف الدائر حول من له
الحق في بسط النفود وهذا الحق يتمزق في
منافسه محتدمه بين المكون العشائري العربي
والاكراد الذين يشكلون غالبيه قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه المدعومه من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
توتر الاوضاع في دير الزور يتزامن مع حراك
معارض يتجدد في الشمال السوري وفي الجنوب
كذلك تحديدا في السويداء ودرعه وهذا
التزامن يطرح علامات استفهام عن سياقات
اكبر في ضوء محاولات امريكيه مستمره لوضع
حد لتمدد الفصائل المواليه لايران في
المنطقه ولنفود الروسي جوا وبرا والى ان
تتضح الصوره تتوسع دائره الاشتباكات بين
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه والمجلس العسكري
لدير الزور حتى بلغ الامر بمم ثلي العشائر
ان يطالبوا التحالف الدولي بالتدخل خصوصا
بعد ان فرضت قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه حصارا
على قاده المجلس داخل مدينه الحسكه المشهد
ينذر بعواقب وخيمه اذا لم تفرش قوه السريه
الديمقراطيه عن المحتجزين فبيان العشائر
كان واضحا اما اطلاق سراحهم او ان تتحول
قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه لهدف مشروع لابناء
العشائر